this may look like a giant tent but it's
actually one of qatar's eight stadiums
that'll be used in the 2022 World Cup
holding up to 60 000 fans Alberta is one
of the biggest stadiums at the
tournament and nine matches including
the opening will be held here
the design was inspired by baton shot at
tents used by qatar's nomadic tribes and
others across the region the black
stripes around the exterior and the
patterns throughout the entire Stadium
are also inspired by qatar's traditions
the roof is retractable to help control
the shade and maintain temperatures
inside and it can be opened or closed
within 20 minutes
it's the only Stadium out of the eight
that have hotel rooms inside of it you
can even see the pitch from the room
the stadium is about 35 kilometers north
of Doha in a city called which is known
for its fishing and purling history
after the World Cup the stadium will be
downsized to 32 000 seats and the top
tiers will be turned into a hotel
restaurants and other facilities but
before that it's time for some football
[Applause]